good morning Hank and welcome to my new
camcorder it's Tuesday it's question
Tuesday the day that I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters how
long is the project for awesome been
going on this will be the third year how
do I get my girlfriend to love me more
than Jacob black okay the first thing
you want to do is you want to see if
your torso can be contorted into a V
because that's a helpful start then
become really hairy but only sometimes
wait what is the project for awesome how
do I make a video and where do I post it
the project for awesome is an annual
tradition in which lots of people make
videos for charities they care about and
then lots of other people rate and
favorite and comment on those videos
over and over and over again so that for
one day the most popular videos on
YouTube aren't about boobs or hamsters
on piano but about decreasing world suck
if you want to make a video just make
one advocating for your favorite charity
uploaded on Thursday and ideally find a
way to make sure that the thumbnail of
your video is this which you can find
out a link in the doobly-doo and then
get your rating and commenting fingers
ready for 48 hours of fun this guy I
really like wants my advice on how to
ask out another girl what should I do
alright listen this is gonna sound crazy
but I have a suspicion that the guy in
question actually likes you I might be
wrong about this but boys commonly have
this insane strategy wherein we tell the
girl we like that we need advice on how
to ask out a different girl I realize
this is a colossal estupid strategy but
if you look in comments I bet you'll see
a lot of guys who are like yeah I have
done that what time should I upload my
project for awesome video as close to
noon eastern time as possible which is 5
p.m. GMT how do I get a woman's
attention to see if she likes me we've
been friends for a while so my logical
thought is that I should grow a mustache
am i far off see girl that is how we
think we're like maybe I should grow a
mustache to get her attention
wait what can I do for project for
awesome if I can't make a video ok 90%
of the project for awesome is not in
making videos it's in commenting and
rating upon videos there will be a live
show that goes from Thursday at noon
until Saturday morning we're going to
use that live show by the way there will
be a link on Thursday morning to
organize to go from video to video to
video making sure that we get tons and
tons of comments and ratings and
favorites on each one and it will only
work if there are a lot of us so come
and spend as much of your Thursday and
Friday as possible with Hank and me I
promise it'll be fun if you like nerdy
fun which let's face it you do how do I
get my ex girlfriend back read up on
Buddhas not a
link in the dooblydoo how do I get the
picture that I can download in the
doobly-doo to be the thumbnail in my
video unfortunately that's pretty hard
we think we've cracked YouTube's
algorithm you can find out more at
projectforawesome.com but if that
doesn't work just do your best to be
creative about the thumbnail and
remember that it can be a great project
for awesome video even without the
thumbnail you have a lot of advice about
guys and girls who want to find each
other but what about gay people same
advice different pronouns any advice on
how to make my project for awesome video
good yeah remember that you're not just
talking about a charity you're trying to
add the Cape for that charity so try to
be as creative and awesome as possible
also you might want to find creative
ways to encourage fundraising I for
example will be auctioning off my one
and only pair of nerd glasses which I
wore for most blog brothers videos in
2008 what's the best way to tell a close
friend that you're a nerdfighter like
with them I would show them this video
in fact pause it right now go get that
person and bring them back hi there this
is John green of the vlogbrothers you
have a close friend in nerdfighteria who
kind of likes you no big deal don't
freak out and don't reveal anything
don't tell them what you're feeling yet
pokerface pup pup pup pup pup pup pup
pup poker face think it through before
you respond and remember this isn't like
some oh I can't live without you think
this is a I like you if you like me but
if you don't like me that's cool our
friendship is wonderful and I don't want
to put it in jeopardy thing but you know
if you're open to the idea this person
does think you're sort of adorable what
is the right age to start having sex hmm
42 hey the bookcase is that different
from your old bookcase yes it is why'd
you change where you film no there are a
bunch of reasons the whole home REE
holy snoot is that a cramp what is it
the Yeti is gonna have a little
Yeti win kitty
Willie what do you think about this
whole baby business I'm concerned